[Musique]
oh
on
des visages plein d'espoir une jeunesse
réunionnaise qui va construire le
département de demain ces étudiants ont
pour point commun d'avoir sauté la mer
une mobilité accompagnés par les aides
de la collectivité départementale à
travers le portail net bourse aux lions
[Musique]
à brest il ya nice à lyon commerce
tout commence à la réunion dans un
moment délicat celui du choix de la
mobilité la direction de l'éducation le
sait bien raison pour laquelle une
grande journée d'information permet aux
étudiants de rassembler toutes les
épaisseurs
vous êtes présent pour un bien sûr un
projet de mobilité pour la première fois
pour la plupart d'entre vous
cette journée permet effectivement de
les rassurer de les guider dans le bon
parcours enfin essayez du moins de de
bien faire en sorte que d'avoir les
meilleures réponses possibles pour ces
jeunes
mais effectivement ces données à prendre
en considération surtout ses parents qui
voient ils leur enfant partir vers
l'inconnu et il existe des solutions
notamment le département à travers ces
différents dispositifs mais beau des
dispositifs qui permettent à nos jeunes
qui veulent étudier à paris des
conditions de logement bien adapté la
région effectivement à par rapport à la
continuité territoriale par rapport à
ladom donc vraiment c'est ces
institutions là sont là aujourd'hui pour
guider et orienter et faire en sorte que
les jeunes s'y retrouvent parfaitement
ses étudiants bénéficient de plusieurs
types dette de la collectivité une prime
d'installation une bourse départementale
l'aide au financement des études et
quelques logements à la cité
universitaire internationale de paris
des dispositifs variable selon le
plafond des parents les aides
financières du département sont
en partie financé par l'union européenne
via le fonds social à l'emploi et donc
dans ce cadre là le département se doit
de montrer comment il fait
l'accompagnement des étudiants afin que
ça ne soit pas juste un guichet
financier sur lequel on émarge mais bien
un accompagnement global sur un projet
de mobilité est une des obligations de
ces financements européens réside dans
l'obligation de contrôler le bien fondé
de ces vases investissements direction
donc la métropole à la rencontre de ses
étudiants
[Musique]
paris la capitale la plus grande ville
étudiante de france avec un demi million
d'étudiants les rennais sont donc
statistiquement très nombreux logements
et nerveux vie chère mégalopole
internationale les problématiques ne
manquent pas appuyé par l'antenne de
paris les agents du département
s'apprête à rencontrer les étudiants
réunionnais de paris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de l'autre côté de la ville cam il fait
partie de ces étudiants boursiers il un
logement la cité universitaire
internationale de paris
ici c'est là qu'a fait que pat les
foires et autres
les gens travaillent pendant la journée
il ya deux positions qui sont
importantes pour moi
dans le cas de la cité c'est que ont
réussi à avoir un loyer qui est assez
faible
donc ça nous permet de profiter
autrement de la vie à paris et le loyer
aujourd'hui moi je paye 399 euros près
j'ai la chance d'avoir le statut
étudiant entrepreneur qui est un statut
qui est qui et qui est tout récent et
qui me permet d'avoir même si je suis
plus vraiment étudiants g parce que je
terminais à l'essec
j'ai quand même le les avantages d'un
étudiant j'ai les frais de transport qui
sont un peu moins élevé et j'ai tous les
avantages qu'un étudiant
direction la mairie de paris pour la
rencontre avec les étudiants réunionnais
et ce soir là sa maman l'accompagnent
l'ailé donc les chirurgien orl deuxième
fille karine qui a fini son cursus
d'ingénieur et qui monte une société une
une start-up voilà et la troisième et en
quatrième année de sages femmes et trois
ont bénéficié des aides départementales
bon mais de camilla bénéficiant en plus
de cette aide pour les frais de
scolarité qui nous a vraiment très grand
rendu un grand service et ainsi que le
logement à la cu et qui était vraiment
appréciable pour le budget familial
moi je pense que quand on veut vraiment
réussi il faut taper à toutes les portes
et quand on veut vraiment on peut parier
contre une expérience et celle des
hommes osent y découvrir peut-être
encore plus sur ce que le conseil
général à 12 a déposé ce qu'on peut vous
leur proposez aussi peut-être
sur une carte sim au t1 et si nous ment
à temps consacré à leurs ennemis dans sa
cabine doucement de l'humanité
premier contact et préparation des
dispositifs dont ils ont bénéficié
et rapidement les premières questions et
c'est une chanson que je peux bénéficier
d'une hausse si j'ai fait des stages de
plus de 6 si par exemple je demande
c'est dans la région je perde mais elle
est partante
enfin ce qui fait que du coup elle à la
situation et enfin les ducs outre est
montré dans son renouveau
mais du coup très spécifique je pensais
de justement prouvé toutes ces
informations
enfin si elle pas eu ce soir j'aurais
bien entre étudiants 60 tout de suite
tout seul parce qu'on a pu la famille en
fait derrière nous et en fait en
cherchant un petit peu en se renseignant
auprès des institutions des mairies des
réseaux d'associations on se rend
toujours content que la réunion est
présente à travers toute la france et
même à travers le monde et on a juste à
chercher à trouver les bons sites pour
avoir tous les contacts réunionnais près
de chez soi même s'il paraît compliqué
de faire du cas par cas
adapter les dispositifs aux contraintes
1 semble être la première demande
titre écouté cet accompagnement et est
censée mesure là je suis pas sûr que
j'aurais pu me voir cette cette qualité
de vie et cet accompagnement dans la
réussite actuellement les échanges des
réunionnais savoir à quels problèmes ils
ont été confrontés savoir qu'à des
associations qui existent
voir aussi que les réunionnais qui
viennent des mêmes villes que nous des
mêmes promotions de nous voir ce qu'ils
font aujourd'hui ça fait toujours
plaisir
je pense que pour tous les étudiants
réunionnais on devrait faire ça crée un
réseau de manière à s'entraider et met
la réunion en l'air quoi ça que
j'aimerais faire autour du goût pays
ces primes aux étudiants ont pu échanger
avec les agents du département
objectif leur réussite aujourd'hui nous
avons trois mille jeunes années
qui essaime les différents bassins
universitaire qui fréquentent des écoles
extrêmement
variez grandes écoles et qui font
effectivement l'honneur de la famille de
leurs parents mais également le lien de
réunion cette mission est dû au fait que
pour la première fois nous avons
35 millions
le soutien de l'union européenne
sur sept ans donc 5 millions par an ce
qui est intéressante et m2
d'effets de levier aux conditions
optimisées deux aides
et ensuite
dans ce cadre rien ne vaut
les rencontres les échanges doit
améliorer les dispositifs existants et
pour prendre en compte effectivement des
problèmes spécifiques
[Musique]
bienvenu à bordeaux cinquante six mille
étudiants des dizaines d'écoles et
universités une ville plus ensoleillé où
les primes aux étudiants ont toujours le
sourire
toutes les trois villes feu ce soir
paris bordeaux 2e étape gnocchis va
terminer qui va clôturer cette rencontre
organisée par intéressant de la mobilité
en collaboration avec l'antenne de paris
on a gardé le même schéma de cause et en
est venu à venir
[Musique]
comme à paris cette rencontre conviviale
permet d'échanger avec ses crayons
politain de leur contexte dans cette vie
métropolitaine et pour cela rien ne vaut
une expérience la réussite est possible
il faut se dire que c'est quand même une
grande opportunité parce que pour nous
étudiants réunionnais c'est un privilège
d'avoir ces aides
parce que les étudiants métropolitain et
n'ont pas droit à ces élans j'ai
peut-être pu avoir plus d'opportunités
être moins dans l'inquiétude et me faire
comment dire être plus ouvert au voyage
par exemple parce que moi j'ai fait six
mois à dublin par exemple trois mois en
angleterre aussi à leeds donc c'est
quand même quelque chose de conséquent
si on sait qu'on n'a pas forcément ces
aides
on va pas penser à le faire on va se
restreindre dans notre cursus il est bon
de donner des aides mais il faut aussi
après évalué voir ce que deviennent les
étudiants sur place comment il se
débrouille
comment ils s'installent quels sont les
freins quelles sont les problématiques
qu'ils rencontrent pendant cette
installation et il s'agit donc dans le
cadre de ses rencontres de recueillir un
certain nombre d'informations
d'expériences et des délais proposés par
ailleurs aux futurs étudiants qui
s'inscriront à la prochaine rentrée
universitaire face à toutes ces
informations ce réseau les langues se
délient et chacun espère plus de cet
accompagnement à c'est vraiment utile
parce que çà et là la bourse nationale
bah ça me permet de vivre
on sent que mes parents aient besoin de
trop tron données comme les jeunes de la
réunion où verizon de sortir de la
réunion et tenter leur chance ici et
même si tous n'ont pas forcément les
moyens ils pourront réussir
avant c'était vraiment où sont tous
passés via le site internet du coup
maintenant on peut rencontrer les gens
donc on peut exposer notre cas
particulier donc on peut nous répondre
ou nous orienter vers d'autres d'autres
organismes
voilà et oui comment comme on a dix
mille kilomètres c'est pas facile déjà
de les avoir passé quelques décalages
horaires deux fois pour téléphoner pour
les joindre par mail et web voilà c'est
l'essai et c'est difficile et du coup
comme ils viennent
ah non là c'est beaucoup plus facile on
peut se poser des questions l'idée c'est
vraiment de les accueillir nous faisons
maintenant vous n'êtes pas tout seul
parce que souvent on se retrouve on est
dans notre classement on a des amis oui
mais voilà on appelait tout seul et
c'est pas trop où aller
voilà c'est vraiment les accueillir mais
pas forcément rester entraîneur
prononcer vraiment ouvrir la culture et
voilà fait découvrir que
là telle ou telle chose qui est possible
de faire ses échanges avec les agents de
la collectivité sont souvent la source
de beaucoup de solutions
là ce sont des questions qui sortent du
dispositif actuel la question et je ne
rentre pas dans ce cadre là qu'est ce
que vous pouvez faire pour mais dès que
ça va nous permettre d'innover
notre processus de travail notre façon
que nous avons d'attribuer les bourses
parce que les choses évoluent comme
toute chose il faut faire évoluer donc
là je crois que c'est vraiment
l'occasion de se pencher dessus et de
voir comment ouvrir avec les moyens
qu'on a
certes après un pic à merci
[Applaudissements]
dernière étape de cette mission à la
rencontre des étudiants réunionnais lyon
également une des plus grosse ville
étudiante de france
[Musique]
l'occasion d'aller à la rencontre de ces
grosses enseignes de formation des
étudiants dans cette école de commerce
high tech les réunionnais ou un
traitement adapté
on organise des concours on va parler de
l'école et parler des différents
programmes auprès des étudiants qui sont
à la réunion
et puis ensuite une fois qu'ils arrivent
sur place on a un petit process
d'accueil où on va les mettre en
relation avec des anciens des actuels
les aider à s'intégrer dans le
microcosme lyonnais dans leur recherche
d'appartement et dans le suivi de leurs
études étant donné qu'on a l'habitude
nous d'accueillir des étudiants qui
viennent de la réunion tous ses process
sont assez rodée donc ça nous permet
aussi de faciliter leur paiement parce
qu'on sait qu'ils attendent ces bourses
donc voilà on patiente a assez
facilement on met en place des
échéanciers en fonction des bourses qui
devront recevoir donc on a connaissance
de ce dispositif et on fait en sorte que
du coup nos nos échéances et notre façon
de payer l'école s'adapte aux
dispositifs mis en place
[Musique]
ce contact est essentiel puisqu'il
permet effectivement de lever les freins
pour permettre à l'étudiant de
s'installer et de s'inscrire dans des
meilleures conditions dans l'école en
question
[Musique]
à quelques minutes de tram d'autres
étudiants réunionnais sont venus à la
conférence programmée par le département
de la réunion seul ou accompagné le
premier contact a semblé un moment
privilégié
c'est l'administration finalement de
casser la barrière d'y aller de venir
chercher l'information
bien sûr nous sommes dans une opération
qui consiste précisément à aller vers
nous allons vers des jeunes réunionnais
et je pense que lorsqu'on va
effectivement dans des villes où se
trouvent les étudiantes et étudiants
réunionnais il faut que nous puissions
au delà de ce protocole de cette réunion
un petit peu ce panel encore une fois
les discuter directement
simple avec que les uns les autres biens
[Musique]
étudiante et
en fait j'étais en vacances pour venir
voir ma fille est en même temps il y
avait cette réunion avec les étudiants
de lyon donc j'ai profité pour venir
avec elle les lieux département comptait
beaucoup pour moi beaucoup et quand peu
son école est payante donc ça a permis
de payer sa première année une fois de
plus les questions étaient techniques et
variés réseau jeunesse au travers
justement c'est un réseau qui est là
pour valoriser mettre en avant les
jeunes ultramarins dont la réunion bien
évidemment fait partie des autres maires
donc on est là pour dire aux réunionnais
on est là on ne vous oublie pas vous
aussi vous avez des compétences vous
avez
vous avez les des expériences qu'on peut
qu'on pourrait mettre en avant donc
n'hésitez pas à vous rapprocher de nous
je pense que c'est un frein pour
certains qui ne connaissent pas cette
aide justement
de dire enfin ils se disent peut-être
que ça sera pas possible
d'aller dans cette telle ou telle école
alors que la région le département et
derrière eux pour pour les aider juste
vient déjà en métropole parce que on a
beaucoup plus de peut-être plus de
formation peut-être plus précise ça
c'est quand même un plus et puis après
on revient à adopter ils pensent
honorable voilà ce la réunion comprendre
les attentes des partenaires à la fin de
cette mission
les agents du département rentre pas
tout à fait comme ils sont arrivés on
est quoi ce que nous rappelle ce soir
google
un accompagnement global sur un projet
de mobilité au bénéfice de notre
jeunesse
le département se veut aller coûte la
seule étape obligatoire restera
[Musique]